blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman all right the big foreign
policy news overnight is that joe biden
is going to
leave afghanistan on the schedule he
most recently put in place which is
august 31st and i have to tell you
foreign policy is very complicated
foreign policy typically has ifs ands
and buts but as many of you have
continued to email me about some in
agreement some in disagreement
this is one of the clearest and most
black white sort of decisive
ways that i've seen foreign policy
carried out and i agree with it 100 and
we're going to talk about why but the
big news is that indeed joe biden is
confirming that the united states will
keep its august 31st deadline saying
yesterday the sooner we finish the
better joe biden said yesterday the u.s
is on track to complete its hurried
airlift in afghanistan by august 31st
acknowledging he does not plan to keep
american troops in the country any
longer
even as questions remain over who will
be able to leave and when
in late afternoon remarks at the white
house biden recognize the success of the
mission will depend largely on
cooperation from the taliban he said
he's asked military leaders to be ready
with contingency options to adjust the
timetable if it becomes necessary we are
currently on pace to finish by august 31
he said i am determined to complete our
mission
um this is
completely the right decision
now
on cost alone looking at what has been
spent in afghanistan over the last 20
years
leaving is completely justified uh
unfailed policy alone meaning
we aren't making any progress there and
in fact the longer we stay
uh we are merely delaying the inevitable
while spending more money on failed
policy alone you could justify leaving
on the length of time we've been there
alone you could even maybe justify
leaving meaning even if you could
justify the cost which you can't
even if you could make the case that you
were somehow succeeding which we aren't
just the fact that it's been 20 years
would in some sense justify leaving but
it's all of these things and more and we
have to be able to look at it and say uh
barack obama was wrong to stay there
donald trump was wrong to stay there
joe biden is right to leave that's the
big picture and the rest of it is
details now they are important details
they're they're the details are
important for sure like for example did
we adequately plan for getting people
out and that includes americans but that
also includes what is happening from the
standpoint of refugees did we plan
appropriately for the humanitarian
fallout and on and on
but we have now evacuated more than 70
000 people and here is joe biden
explaining it
as of this afternoon we've helped
evacuate 70
700 people just since august the 14th
75
900 people since the end of july
just in the past 12 hours
another 19 u.s military flights
18 c-17s and one c-130 carrying
approximately 6
400 evacuees
and 31 coalition flights carrying 5 600
people have left kabul
just in the last 12 hours
a total of 50 more flights 12 000 more
people since i updated you this morning
these numbers are a testament to the
efforts of our brave service women and
men
to our diplomats on the ground in kabul
and to our allies still standing with us
and as i tweeted to much reaction last
night
biden gets out of a 20-year quagmire in
afghanistan
evacuates more than 70 000 people and as
of now no americans have died and we're
supposed to believe that this is bad
and you've seen
fox news say it's bad
because of course it's biden you've seen
other media outlets sometimes considered
left sometimes considered centrist
sometimes merely just corporate media
outlets play up well shouldn't we
maintain a presence shouldn't we stay
etc
no no and this has really exposed the
kind of corporatist pro it's not even
really pro-war it's just pro-foreign
intervention
status quo or default position of so
many of the media outlets even
considered to be left by some
um
so now we get to the details and of
course the details are important
afghanistan fell to the taliban in a
weekend
now there are some who are looking at
that and are saying well that's evidence
that we didn't handle the withdrawal
appropriately i would actually say the
opposite
i would say that if after 20 years
afghanistan fell to the taliban in a
weekend
there was nothing you could do to
prevent that from happening sooner or
later if you left and the fact that it
happened in a weekend is proof that we
should be out of there we should have
left sooner not stayed long longer
so this is arguably the best thing that
joe biden has done
and you have to really look at the
motivations of the different people that
are criticizing the decision there are
some on the left who are criticizing the
decision merely because they want to
show their progressive credentials and
they want to criticize biden no matter
what that's some people
similarly there are those on the right
who are ignoring the fact that donald
trump had the exact same plan it would
have been carried out in the exact same
way no matter what he tells you and they
are saying well no no no biden did it
wrong trump would have done it correctly
they are obviously incorrect about that
as well
uh and then of course you have the fact
that so much of the media
is saying was this actually right should
we have stayed
that confirms as i mentioned this kind
of status quo pro-intervention bias the
issues now are can we continue getting
americans out safely and how many afghan
lives can we also save
and that has to be a priority as well
but if we look at everything joe biden
has done so far
this is one of the major accomplishments
this has been a 20-year quagmire started
by george w bush
we arguably never should have gone
if we did we should have left what 18 17
years ago i mean that's in the most
generous point the most generous
interpretation
and we can't fall for
the concern trolls quite frankly as what
they are on both sides so if you want to
email me and say well this could have
been better planned or that could have
been better planned sure i'll probably
agree with you but this was a decisive
uh uh of action by joe biden it was the
right decisive action and the idea that
we should be criticizing him for finally
getting us out is uh really it's it's
depressing to see
from how many different sides that's the
perspective that we are seeing
hey i want to talk about something
called havana syndrome this is super
interesting uh and also pretty scary i i
actually had not really read much about
this until yesterday
i'll tell you what the news is and then
i'm going to talk to you about what
havana syndrome is so
article from cnn possible havana
syndrome incident delayed kamala harris
flight to vietnam look at this
vice president kamala harris's departure
for vietnam was delayed by several hours
tuesday afternoon
after her office was informed by the u.s
embassy in hanoi vietnam of a quote
report of a recent possible anomalous or
anomalous both acceptable health
incident
that term is the way that the government
usually refers to the mysterious havana
syndrome that has sickened hundreds of
u.s officials over the past few years
uh rachel chen
spokeswoman for the u.s embassy in hanoi
said earlier this evening the vice
president's traveling delegation was
delayed from departing singapore because
the vice president's office was made
aware of a report of a recent possible
anomalous health incident in hanoi after
careful assessment the decision was made
to continue with the vice president's
trip
aboard air force two harris's chief
spokeswoman simone sanders told
traveling reporters that harris is quote
well all is fine and looking forward to
meetings in hanoi tomorrow this has
nothing to do with the vice president's
health harris eventually took off from
singapore's paella bar air base after a
more than three hour delay so what is
this havana syndrome this is absolutely
wild
uh havana syndrome is a set of medical
signs and symptoms reported by u.s and
canadian embassy staff in cuba dating
back to late 2016 as well as
subsequently in some other countries
including the u.s austria and germany
in 2017 donald trump accused cuba of
perpetrating unspecified attacks causing
these symptoms the u.s reduced staff at
their embassy to a minimum response in
2018 u.s diplomats in china reported
problems similar to those reported in
cuba
as did undercover cia agents working in
other countries with partner agencies to
counter russian covert operations
subsequent studies of the affected
diplomats in cuba published in the
journal jama in 2018
found evidence that the diplomats
experienced some form of brain injury
but did not determine the cause of the
injuries while there is no expert
consensus on the cause of the symptoms a
co-author of the jama study considered
microwave weapons to be a main suspect
of the phenomenon u.s national academies
of sciences engineering and medicine
expert committee concluded in december
of 2020 that microwave energy
specifically directly pulsed rf energy
quote appears to be the most plausible
mechanism in explaining these cases
among those that the committee
considered but that each possible cause
remains speculative so understand what
the the speculation is the idea here is
knowing where there are diplomats at
embassies as one example
uh adversaries or other intelligence or
security agencies
may be directing microwave
uh
weapons
at these embassies to cause symptoms
in
individuals
in terms of the symptoms
they include hearing loss
memory loss and nausea
speculation centered around a sonic
weapon with some researchers pointing to
infrasound as a possible cause
this has led to the us expelling cuban
diplomats this has led to the u.s state
department removing non-essential staff
from the embassy in cuba
donald trump said he believes cuba is
responsible this goes well beyond cuba
actually in reality
and if you look at theories regarding
cause there is microwaves as one
previously proposed were ultrasound via
intermodulation distortion
cricket noises and exposure to
neurotoxic pesticides
pesticides or infectious agents being
looked at
and then also the possibility of a
psychogenic origin some individuals
speculate without evidence that the
symptoms represent episodes of mass
hysteria that appears to not be the case
and with something like this we've got
to be careful to separate
speculative and completely unfounded
possible causes from those that are
actually showing up in the uh medical
literature so what is is this a form of
uh is is this a form of uh terrorism is
this a is this a an action of war are
these intelligence operations it's
absolutely bizarre i had heard nothing
about this i don't even remember the
trump stuff with cuba in 20 in 2018
but
an absolutely incredible situation
and havana syndrome is what it is it is
called
what should this be considered if indeed
it is as reported um and what should be
the reaction of the united states i
don't know i just learned about this
stuff in the last 12 hours i'd be
curious to hear from you you can find me
on twitter at deepakman we will take a
quick break and after the break we're
going to explore a new medical ethics
study
that asks the question when it comes to
covin
would it be fair to treat vaccinated
patients first would it be fair to take
vaccination into consideration in terms
of triage we'll talk about that right
after this short break
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video all right let's
jump uh jump right into this topic it's
a big topic uh it's a complicated one
over the last several weeks i've gotten
a ton of emails from you guys uh calls
with people asking or suggesting uh
maybe if you are unvaccinated and you
get very sick with covet and you go to
the hospital you should be refused
treatment um and of course that's not
going to happen in any real way there
are uh primary care doctors that are
saying our practice will only treat
we'll only have on our roster vaccinated
patients but if you go to an emergency
room you are not going to be denied
treatment because you are unvaccinated
for better or worth worse ethical
unethical it that's just not going to
happen but there are now new
uh questions it's a much more narrow
discussion and the discussion is whether
it would be fair to treat vaccinated
coveted patients
first and this is more of a triage
conversation so really it's a question
of whether vaccination status
should or could be considered in terms
of triage and there's some pretty good
arguments to suggest that it should
uh which we are going to get into uh
interesting wired article which asks
would it be fair to treat vaccinated
coveted patients first last week texas
healthcare policymakers discussed taking
vaccination status into account for cova
triage it's a larger conversation
ethicists are bracing for
um
it's no accident that people describe
something that's calculated cold and
unemotional as clinical taking care of
people's health isn't it health isn't
emotion free by any means
but the clinic is where physicians and
nurses have to make life and death
decisions under time pressure including
which patients go first and what kind of
care they get when resources like say
ventilators or intensive care beds
oxygen staff and time or scarce
that decision making is called triage
and last week the dallas morning news
reported
that some texas hospitals were
considering a massive change to how they
do it the question in play
would it make sense to take into account
the vaccination status of their coveted
patients with icus filling up with
severely ill coveted patients and a
shortage of beds and nurses should
clinicians all other things being equal
that's an important part of it
care for vaccinated people before or
differently than unvaccinated ones and
the article goes on to say it hasn't
happened and probably won't the idea
came from a memo
um this is this is a very complicated
question fundamentally this is not about
ignoring the hippocratic oath and saying
don't treat unvaccinated patients
uh they haven't taken care of themselves
assuming there's no real medical reason
why they are unvaccinated
we're going to ignore these people that
that's not what this is about
this is about
including vaccination status as part of
triage
where someone may end up getting less
care or might end up getting no care
depending on how full an emergency room
is in a moment i'll tell you about three
emergency rooms that are so full they've
closed
um and whether
the vaccination status affects chance of
recovery
uh and you could on this basis say all
right you've got
a 65 year old vaccinated patient
and a 60 year old unvaccinated patient
and if you don't consider vaccination
status you might just go by how severe
are their symptoms their age etc if you
consider vaccination status you would
have this statistical framework in which
you know
that hospitalized vaccinated patients
are more likely to survive than
unvaccinated patients that would be a
way to empirically
not in some kind of moralistic
punishment way but empirically consider
vaccination status in triage is a
vaccinated 50 year old more likely to
recover
than an unvaccinated
40 year old and there's even another
aspect of this which is if you have a
patient in the er or in the icu or
potentially going into the icu
and they're unvaccinated and they're
unvaccinated for no other reason other
than they fell for conspiracy theories
does it stand to reason that they may
generally be less likely to heed the
advice that they are given in that
hospital if granted an intensive care
unit would it be fair to consider that
as well and of course there's there's
the important inclusion of the idea all
else being equal and really the the i
think the gist here
is not to make
unclear triage calls about a vaccinated
55 year old and an unvaccinated 40 year
old but really more about situations
where it's almost identical situations
you might have two people
equally sick
same age
one vaccinated one unvaccinated and you
have one spot in the icu would it be
fair to say we're going to take the
vaccinated patient because statistically
they're more likely to recover and in
general they are probably more likely to
heed our advice this is not
unheard of
elsewhere
uh on the basis of a a different sort of
sort of health considerations alcoholics
historically
have been considered unsuitable for
liver transplants because of the
presumed high risk of relapsing to
excessive drinking which could ruin the
transplanted liver that's that's a
lifestyle choice that is factored into
organ donation although there are people
who rightly say well it's not really a
lifestyle choice alcoholism is a disease
and then it becomes more complex but the
point is that it is it's similar it's
analogous to some degree triage is about
chances of survival but it's also about
available resources it's also about
patient willingness to comply with
medical advice and people who are
vaccinated are not only more likely to
survive they've shown a motivation
to follow the widely accepted medical
advice and ultimately this is about
available resources and we've talked
before and i'm going to give you an
example in the next story of this
when you have a full icu
with disproportionately unvaccinated
people not because of a medical
condition that says don't get vaccinated
but because they've chosen not to get
vaccinated if you get into a car
accident if you have a heart attack if
you have a work injury
and you're vaccinated and you go in for
something serious not related to covid
you may not be able to get the treatment
you need because of people who have
simply chosen not to get vaccinated and
so there is an element of this which is
that people who are not looking out for
society are consuming resources and
hurting other people people who maybe
would survive after that car crash if
they could get right into an icu but the
icu is full because of unvaccinated
people so i think it's completely
reasonable to take it into account in
triage i'm not saying you don't provide
treatment
but the question about triage
considerations seems completely logical
to me now if you want an example
of just how bad this is now getting in
terms of uh consuming medical resources
there are now three emergency rooms that
have had to close in texas because
there's just too much covet memorial
hermann closes three stand-alone
emergency rooms in greater houston
covid 19 surge prompts resource
management for hospital system memorial
hermann announced monday that due to the
continued covet-19 surge and the strain
on the hospital systems operation it was
closing three of its 24-hour emergency
rooms as a 5 pm monday until further
notice
the 3 ers are uh in kingwood spring and
siena texas statement from the media
relations team says patients who are
currently receiving care inside any of
these emergency rooms will be safely
discharged or transferred to another
memorial hermann facility members of our
community who require emergent care
should proceed to another nearby
emergency center for assistance
closing these locations allows us to
reassign the staff to other locations
where their help is critically needed it
also eliminates the need to transfer
these patients to the main hospital for
admission if necessary so what's
happening is that overall the strain is
so huge
that they need to close these centers to
send people elsewhere to deal with the
coveted surge and this is exactly the
point we've been talking about now for
several weeks we had a video during a
live stream from a doctor in louisiana
who commented about this very eloquently
this affects everyone who might need an
er
if you drive your car
you could get into an accident if a kid
goes to school or camp where they could
get hurt
they might not have access to an
emergency room these three emergency
rooms are now closed period to everybody
because the staff need to go elsewhere
to deal with covet patients most of whom
are unvaccinated so this is not
hypothetical these are now three
emergency rooms not available the
vaccine is free remember the vaccine is
free
texas
has been crazy lately you had their go
it alone libertarian electrical grid
which left them without power when the
storms hit
then they had a heat wave causing such a
demand on electricity that they started
restricting people's power availability
turning down people's smart thermostats
and now they have emergency room rooms
close and closing and there's a real
good chance
that this this gets even worse in
november december and january hopefully
we're seeing a leveling off of the delta
variant wave it's not clear yet we maybe
we may not be the growth rate is slowing
but we're about to head into flu season
and it's at least suspected
that there's a flu-like seasonality to
covid
still to be seen if it happens again
this year it happened last year
situation was different we didn't yet
have vaccines out now we do and this is
once again raising that question that we
talked about in the last segment should
unvaccinated people be deprioritized in
some way not ignored
not denied care but should vaccination
status by choice
um exempting those who can't get the
vaccine because of some specific
condition should vaccination status be
considered
in terms of triage we're going to
continue talking about exactly that
question
on our instagram make sure you're
following us there at david pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right let's get into some really
really dangerous ignorant pathetic
delusional and even dangerous reactions
to the news of the last 48 hours of the
full approval of the pfizerkovit19
vaccine we predicted and many others did
as well it was obvious that as soon as
the pfizer vaccine was fully approved by
the fda the goalposts would be moved by
the anti-vaccine crowd and all sorts of
new conspiracy theories would come up
i'm going to play for you today this is
video i always struggle with explaining
exactly what this is this is
steve bannon's show former trump advisor
steve bannon's show
the war room
on real america's voice and i don't know
if real america's voice is a cable
channel or just a youtube channel or
maybe they're not even allowed on
youtube i don't really know
steve bannon invites dr gina louden on
to talk about vaccine approval now
you know where this is going if i tell
you we will be speaking to dr gina
louden about the vaccine approval
process you would
sensibly
assume that we're talking about a
medical doctor here especially after the
right said what sir why do they call her
dr jill biden i mean she's a phd in
education
uh or or a educational doctorate um edd
uh they would never do that well no they
are uh actually gina louden is a um she
has a phd in organizational systems from
an online universe an online university
come on guys come on okay so let's get
into it the claim from dr louden is
the vaccine is not really f it's not
really approved now of course it is
approved by the fda she says it's not
really approved and she brings something
up about the placebo group and there's
actually a really interesting topic here
to discuss let's listen and then we'll
discuss where are the grassroots mothers
today and what can our audience is an
activist audience you by the way why do
all of these people um
uh alex jones and bannon and owen
schroyer what's with the whole grash
roots well it's like it's like sean
connery all the conspiracy theorists are
like sean connery let's continue you
know that they love you what can this
audience do today
to start to defend against this right if
they if they're uncertain if they don't
feel they have the information what do
you recommend our audience members do
doctor well first of all you have to
speak up
you have to say things like um referring
to this npr article by richard harris
from february 19th they dissolved the
control group and we're going to talk
about that because she's completely
misleading this study so for the fda to
have approved this without legitimate
data using a control group because they
lost the control group in the middle of
the study she is lying she is lying
um is reprehensible so this is not
really an fda approved
shot right so that's the first thing
you have to go i think rational
ground.com is a great place to go to get
real information on a lot of this that's
not true rational ground is a nutty
website which promotes the ideas that
masks are bad social distancing is bad
ever closing anything is bad so that's
not a reputable website we'll go we'll
go to actual peer-reviewed studies in a
moment they've taken them off of all
social media like they do so many but
the third oh hey hang on whoa whoa whoa
hang on
hang on hang on hang on hang on hang on
what do you mean this is not fda
approved yeah what doctor please tell us
doctor genoa
is fda approved oh but it's fda approved
in a way that no other medication has
ever been approved why do you want to
refer to the article this is not me
talking this is an article by richard
harris well we're going to look at the
article uh npr february 19th you can
read it yourself
they lost the control group in the
middle of the study by f they lost them
yesterday i lost one of my earbuds they
just lost the control group they
couldn't find it kaiser they decided
it was more important that people went
and got the job
than that they finished the study with
an actual control group ah
oh wait a second so oh that's something
different so this is
i i found the article it's an npr
article she so what did what was she
right about
it's an article in npr
it really was published on february 19th
and it really is by richard harris but
what the article
um explains
is that the vaccine was working and as
is the case in many of these phase three
trials
when what you're testing works so much
better than the placebo there's a
medical ethics question about
is it even moral to keep giving people
only the placebo when giving them when
the efficacy signal is so high that
you're potentially killing people by not
giving them the real vaccine and this is
a widely studied
a topic in medical ethics
just
as one example even as it relates to the
covid vaccines there's a study um in
jama one of the premiere of medical
journals called from december of last
year
the ethics of continuing placebo in sars
kovi
vaccine trials and what
is important to talk about
is what's in this second paragraph
according to pfizer bioentec and moderna
interim analyses after approximately two
months of follow-up suggests the
vaccines are ninety to ninety percent
effective at preventing infection
although no peer review of the data has
been conducted to date both companies
now claim they have an ethical
obligation to offer vaccines as soon as
possible to all participants who receive
placebo considering the strong results
and participants contribution to the
research this is not a new issue in
medical science
when there are rules for how you test
things and one is you test things versus
a placebo you consider what is if there
is an effective treatment already you
test them relative to the best treatment
we have you want to demonstrate this not
only works but it's better than the best
thing we have right now
and it's extraordinarily dangerous now
to come up with they lost the control
group no
the vaccines were so effective and
remember at the time this was
pre-delta-variant the efficacy has come
down against delta still very good
against hospitalization and death the
numbers after two full months were so
good that it would they made the call
that it would have been unethical not to
give the people who got the placebo the
actual vaccine these people are very
very dangerous and remember they were
furious that jill biden was being called
dr jill biden because her doctorate is
in education
this is dr gina lauden talking about
vaccines jill biden wasn't even
commenting on medical elements
this is a a
a woman gina louden who's actually
opining about vaccination and they call
her doctor
she has an online phd in organizational
psychology or or something like that
completely immoral completely dangerous
and completely hypocritical as well
let's move on now to our next kind of
wacky video of the day
a woman
spoke before the greenville south
carolina school board uh i believe it
was last night
and she
as far as she's concerned blew the
whistle
saying the cdc has a plot
to shut schools down that's really
what's behind school and educational
suggestions from the cdc the cdc wants
to shut schools down
and turn them into third reich nazi
style concentration camps where children
will be taken from their parents
and um
presumably subjected to experiments or
who the hell knows what now what you're
going to see there's a there's a bunch
of interesting things to look at in this
clip but one of the things you're going
to notice
is that this woman can barely even
articulate what the conspiracy is this
is really common with these people they
get fully sucked into something they
completely believe it they don't even
understand it they can you say explain
it to me that's i would want to know if
the cdc is doing that i would want to
know
and they can barely explain it
remember when i was on i went to los
angeles and i was on the jesse lee
peterson show i went to his uh studio
and um he started going on about
socialism and communism and he was so
confused that i even said to him jesse
you don't even understand your own
conspiracy theories you don't even
understand your own talking points
that's exactly what's going on here so
let's take a look at this and we should
be asking so many questions here
including
why did you wait to blow the whistle on
this at a school board meeting
why not report it to the police or to
actual authorities who of course would
say this is crazy ma'am let's listen
and by the way we i know the audio is
skewed to one channel it's just the
source audio what is called the
shielding approach to prevent coded 19
it is a plan
to shut down schools
and to use them as camps
so you can tell she's so tentative and
she's reading from an article apparently
posted to getter g-e-t-t-r which is like
another one of these failed right-wing
social media networks of some kind she's
she barely understands what she's
reading
to physically isolate men women and
children
now we know that concentration camps
were something that the nazis did okay
but it can come here at any moment and
we need to be
aware
that they can call it something other
than a concentration camp
concentration camp can be disguised as
something like a green zone
and now so now she's going through the
she's so confused she doesn't know what
she's saying it makes no sense even to
her but she believes it
the plan is
to take
the plan talks about the loss of
freedoms
and personal
interactions it talks about taking
children away from their parents
families away from each other and
separating
each separating everyone by genders
my question is okay will the school
board comply to the cdc shooting
approach aka concentration camps now
being
renamed as green zones
and if you if you want a copy i'll be
more than happy to give you one
um to look into to do your own research
on to
see what you think about it it's so
funny because if there was really a plot
by one of the premier
public health organizations of the
united states to turn schools into
concentration camps why would we leave
it up to the greenville school board to
look into just find some articles
we would be
reporting this to every law enforcement
agency we you know the the it's the
absurdity of
this is the plot
would you look into it school board
please
and let's just get to a few more minutes
maybe the most disturbing part is the
people who clap at the end because it is
everyone's personal rights
what you think
and it is
laws can always give us freedoms lulls
but they can always take away our
freedoms too
and this right here could possibly take
away everyone's freedom
and their families from each other thank
you
[Applause]
so then the clapping starts um
i think actually the clapping at the end
may be the scariest part
uh she doesn't understand what she's
reading this is like i remember some i
admit sometimes in school when i was in
elementary school middle school high
school uh i hadn't read the book but i
had to give a book report and so i would
have
printed notes that i didn't really
understand because i didn't actually
read the book
this and it's like i'm painfully looking
through and trying to put together some
kind of coherent book report oral book
report based on a book i haven't read
that's the vibe that i'm getting here
and the people applauding at the end is
of course very scary
she's reading an article that she found
on the internet and i don't know you
know some people wrote to me they said
david is this person being paid i don't
know who would pay her you know you'd
think if you were paying someone to do
this stuff they would be more coherent
uh the speeches at the meetings there's
there's fights taking place at school
board meetings over masks and different
things there's all sorts of different
levels to this um but
i don't understand where these people
come from quite frankly and
maybe maybe she's been injecting bleach
and this is one of the side effects
maybe she's been
bathing in ivermectin paste and this is
one of the side effects i don't know
but this is extraordinarily disturbing
stuff and again the fact that anybody
would think
this woman uncovered the plot wow how
did she do it must have been that
research that she did that that's even
plausible to the people in the room it's
a really sad state of affairs and
unfortunately for south carolina south
carolina has been the hub
uh of a lot of weaponized pandemic
disinformation this entire time
fortunately for south carolina their
health care system is not as bad as
mississippi and alabama their
educational system is not as bad as
mississippi and alabama their other
infrastructure is not quite as bad so
they've lucked out even though south
carolina has um a wealth of weaponized
disinformation their infrastructure is
just slightly better than some of the
states that are 49th 48th 50th that
their coveted numbers are not quite as
bad as some of those other states it's
truly remarkable uh we'll be back right
after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right
let's take a little bit of a visit to
fantasyland today donald trump's former
press secretary kaylee mcinanni uh
appeared on fox news last night and this
is a really instructive clip in
revisionist history and how quickly
the failed administration is trying to
completely rewrite the past and if you
don't uh if you're not aware of it if
you don't say no we're not going to let
you do that they will gaslight you into
completely forgetting about what went
down for four years before joe biden was
sworn in as president in january of this
year kaylee mcinanny appeared on fox to
talk about how chaotic the biden
administration is the context is
afghanistan as well as joe biden's
diminishing approval rating we've talked
about the diminishing approval rating uh
with trump things were different but
typically presidents come into office
with higher approval ratings and they
sort of diminish over time and we've
talked about the dynamics of why
kaylee says during trump's presidency
you didn't have crisis after crisis
things weren't chaotic
things were calm
what
and she's able somehow to say it with a
straight face let's take a look at the
clip right we are eight months into a
biden presidency jesse wrap your head
around that we still have three years
and four months left look when president
trump was president you didn't see
crisis after crisis you just didn't see
it can you imagine going on national tv
and saying that with a straight face so
for starters half a million dead from
covet under trump as if it's no big deal
it's the flu open everything no masks
it's a democratic hoax
and then of course i mean i don't have
an hour but the ukraine scandal the
north korean failure the migrant border
crisis attacking reporters and the
institution of a free press using a
sharpie to change a hurricane map merely
to make himself look better going to
puerto rico after a hurricane not
knowing puerto ricans or americans and
then tossing rolls of paper towels like
their basketballs telling people in his
administration to slow down testing
because too much coveted testing is
making him look bad
inciting a riot on january 6th claiming
that an election was stolen and trying
to actually stay in power despite the
fact that he lost you uh i would need an
hour to go through the full list of
crisis a day scandal a day
trump presidency review
does kaylee think we slept through
trump's entire presidency or that we
have collective amnesia and then also
hilariously or just horrifyingly like
this is just the bottom of the barrel
kaylee mcinanni actually says
imagine if joe biden had been in charge
when the virus hit i i shudder to think
about what kovid would have been like
under joe biden we've seen afghanistan
blow up crime in the streets you named
it all what would kovat have been like
because i was in the white house when it
was pretty scary times so there is just
so much there and you know first of all
it's interesting how she admits
it was scary
it was scary times
when covid hit
the entire time she was in the white
house and trump was president neither
she nor trump admitted that it was scary
times she's admitting it now in order to
say it would have been too scary for joe
biden to handle but at the time it was
this is all fine
uh it'll be gone by april freedom and
liberty will be opened by easter 15
cases will soon be zero it's like the
flu on and on now though it was so scary
joe biden never could have handled it
but most importantly
trump's handling of coronavirus was one
of the worst in the world by the numbers
during that first year
when trump was in charge
we scaled up our testing
so slowly that we were constantly behind
the curve
trump wanted testing slowed down he
wouldn't wear a mask he wouldn't tell
people to wear masks he played coy with
the whole freedom and liberty thing and
attacked governors that were actually
taking the virus seriously and putting
in place all sorts of different measures
and kaylee mcinanny has the audacity to
come in now
and say imagine if biden had been
president well we'd have had fewer dead
if joe biden had been president wouldn't
be zero of course the virus has ravaged
most countries to some degree
but we would have been far far better
off and so it's important to prevent
them from rewriting history it's
important not to allow them to tell us a
story that is completely divorced from
reality and we must remember that the
trump covet response was a historic
failure some might even even say it was
an historic failure it's more of a
grammatical question than a historical
one but we have to ensure that uh it's
not rewritten and um unfortunately
you know there's just there's just a
reality
that political memories are short even
now when we're seeing joe biden's
approval rating diminish
at least in part because of what has
been a successful campaign to discredit
and attack joe biden's withdrawal from
afghanistan which i am completely in
favor of and consider one of his
major accomplishments getting us out of
a 20-year quagmire in afghanistan talked
about it earlier and earlier this week
so i won't go into it again now
they are um there's the idea of wow what
could this really hurt democrats in 2022
i kind of think it won't
number one because
it's not really the democrats that are
up for re-election it's joe biden and
because political memories really are
short so it's important to remember that
but still we shouldn't allow them to
rewrite history and of course fox news
which
that's one other thing actually i think
is important to mention
we've talked anecdotally over the last
three four weeks
oh look fox isn't doing
as much anti-vaxx propaganda anymore fox
news is sometimes telling the truth
about the safety of the vaccine or
whatever
for the most part and in particular the
nighttime shows although it's on the
daytime shows as well
a fox news is still hosting
promulgating
signal boosting and allowing
really really aggressive propaganda
disinformation misinformation and the
rewriting of history and last night's
kaylee mcinanny appearance
is just more more of the same all right
i don't want to spend a lot of time on
this but i do want to give you a quick
update there is a new trump
reinstatement date now i know you know
for most of you understand what's going
on here which is there is no such thing
as trump's reinstatement uh and
eventually it's just going to be well
the way to reinstate trump is to vote
for him again in 2024 if he runs again
in 2024
but absent the august 13th reinstatement
were now only six days from the end of
august clearly donald trump is not going
to be reinstated in august or at all but
certainly not in august
my pillow ceo mike lindell or mike
pillow for shorthand former guest on
this program
is now saying well it's going to be by
new year's that's the new one our friend
zachary patrizo
writing for salon
pillow magnate turned election
conspiracy theorist mike lindell has a
new prediction donald trump will be back
in the oval office by new year's eve
for months lindell floated august as the
deadline for trump's reinstatement
landing on august 13th as the day
biden's electoral victory would be
thrown out
though the 13th passed without any
developments and his south dakota cyber
symposium fell flat the infamous my
pillow ceo is still in trump's good
grace as earning a glowing endorsement
from the previous commander-in-chief at
a packed rally in coleman alabama
saturday night
trump said mike lindell is a patriot
a wonderful i think he actually said
patriot a wonderful man a man who puts
his guts into everything a man they
don't treat properly he's smart he loves
his country so much he's willing to die
for this country the new one from mike
pillow
is
this year
this year meaning december uh 31st
presumably of 2021 let's take a listen
2022 2024
people want change now we can't wait to
2024 for things to reverse this country
is going down a road right now by the
way this interviewer
i'm pretty sure it's a sycophant because
it's right side broadcasting but if this
were a trolling interviewer he would be
saying the exact same thing we can't
wait till 2024. can we can it happen
sooner
yeah it has to happen now it's trump
2021 100
12 20 21
and it's uh this election when it does
get pulled down you know there are so
many other tickets affected maybe the
supreme court now they just do a whole
new election which is fine but remember
everybody we have to melt down the
machines and make prison bars out of
them that's a fact
aren't the machines plastic anyway how
do you make a prison bar out of it
[Music]
okay so there is mike lindell
this is um this is very much like the
rapture people and it's interesting that
mike lindell is uh a self-professed
religious guy
and uh he talks a lot about how god is
part of what got him out of drug
addiction and so on and so forth to the
extent that that's true that's great
that that
he
says he's no longer
having a problem with with drug
addiction abusive drugs
but uh this is very very much like the
rapture type stuff and we've covered
this before there's the sliding prophecy
dates it's a really important part of
doomsday cults where you have to keep
people going
if you never set a date
people may not follow you because
they're like whatever okay someday but
when when is the date so that kind of
pushes them to set a date
um but then the date comes to pass and
of course nothing happens
and so they have to set a new date and
you've got to keep people hooked and
it's a very common tactic of these
doomsday cults there was
i this is so long ago that i'm having a
hard time remembering
it might have been 2012
where the uh herald camping this was a
an organization let me see if i can
actually find it herald camping
prophecy
um it was 2011 actually where harold
camping a christian radio host said may
21 2011 is going to be the date
and we interviewed a woman i think it
was like april march or april and you
can find the interview on my youtube
channel it's incredible to see
and she is just sure that it's going to
happen
and when i said what if it doesn't she
said you know if it doesn't it means i
wasn't chosen for heaven or something
like that
it didn't happen then they pushed the
date to october 21st apparently harold
camping had like misread the tea leaves
in some way or something like that
obviously it didn't happen we basically
never heard from them again and we tried
to get a follow-up interview with the
woman who was just sure she was getting
raptured on may 21st we never heard back
from her either that's this is basically
a doomsday cult with trump's imaginary
reinstatement which is just as unlikely
as unlikely as you think that i don't
know tomorrow
jesus will return
and people will be raptured and some die
and some go to heaven as unlikely as you
believe that is
trump being reinstated this year is just
as unlikely now you could say well david
one of these things is sort of like
metaphysically impossible right like
there's not going to be this rapture in
theory trump could be president okay
it's
almost as unlikely it is almost as it's
not a physical impossibility but it is
essentially as unlikely that trump will
be reinstated um and the the the
shifting goal posts is a big part of it
and mike lindell is doing exactly that
speaking of mike lindell by the way
let's get to our uh today's voicemail if
you have a message for me i'm still
catching up when i got back from my
vacation i had 650 unlistened voicemails
i'm now down to about 475. i'm working
through it hopefully by
i don't know by mid-september i'll have
i'll have worked through all of it if
you have a voicemail message for me
you can call
219
to davidp
here is a voicemail from someone who i
think makes a really interesting point
about my interview with mike lindell
which was mike lindell didn't even
understand that i was only pretending to
take the interview seriously and that
was by design let's take a listen to
this
hi david this is joe wallen calling in
tucson i just watched your interview
with mike lindell
wow
i have to commend you on the
professionalism
that you showed throughout that
interview
absolutely amazing
on the other hand i feel so bad for mike
he did not
understand that all
what was going on in that interview you
were absolutely amazing but
i hope that man gets some help yeah
it's just sad what's going on with him
just very very sad but once again huge
fan um
love everything you do i try to watch as
much as i can thank you and uh keep up
the good work yeah so
you know i got i i mentioned this a
little bit before
there were people who were upset with my
approach in the mike pillow interview
saying david you let him get away with
saying crazy stuff
it's not that i let him get away it's
that i've done enough of these
interviews where
i know that if i just press every single
uh statement
we don't go anywhere and often the guest
gets angry with me and hangs up so my
approach was let me pretend to take this
seriously if as if it's a real interview
as if this guy's saying anything of
actually connected to the real world
substance and let's just see where he
goes with this stuff um and some people
got it some people didn't some people
liked it some people didn't listen i i
that's that was my approach and it's an
approach i've taken with other cuckoo
for coco puffs uh guests maybe next time
we'll take a different approach we have
a great bonus show planned for you today
we've hopefully worked out most of the
kinks from the standpoint of the bonus
show the house has passed the john lewis
voting rights bill and it is being sent
to the senate it will be a tougher fight
in the senate and we'll talk about
what the outlook is in the senate airbnb
is going to be providing housing to
about 20 000 afghan refugees around the
world at no cost very interesting and
interesting to see different for-profit
companies now
getting weighing in in some way
participating is it posturing is it a
political statement is it both is it
marketing
we'll talk about that we'll get pat's
opinion and oregon is implementing a
mask mandate outdoors outdoors where
there is no evidence the virus actually
spreads
regardless of vaccination status and my
my question is
i'm all on board with the indoor because
we know what the spread is indoor
do you lose people when you go beyond
that and go back to the outdoor stuff
which i think we had figured out are we
better off actually sticking to the
science on that we'll discuss that and
more on today's bonus show how do you
get access to the bonus show very simple
two ways one get a membership at
jointpakman.com very easy you'll be
signed up in 30 seconds and you'll be
listening to or watching today's bonus
show second option if you prefer to
pledge on patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show make
a pledge
and you will also be able to access the
bonus show i will see you then
we're here all week
uh and next week we'll be off on monday
labor day but many many shows between
now and then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman